here in southern Nevada we have women we
have children who are struggling to find
housing and just meet the Basic
Essentials that they need to get by but
there are so many ways that you can help
this very vulnerable population a news
now reporter Joshua peguero Joins us
live this morning to explain what you
can do and it's very simple Joshua
they're holding an essential strive what
do they need
so um good morning Heather and John they
need diapers they need baby wipes they
need pacifiers and again the most
vulnerable population you might not know
that they are you'll see them at the
grocery store in the park as well as
even in school but but hidden or behind
underneath all that these are people
that are so good to get by but luckily
there's an annual baby Essentials drive
and it's being hosted by home Aid and
I'm joined by the director here Taylor
Booth Taylor tell us a little bit about
you've held this event last year how did
it go last year was our most successful
drive yet we collected over twenty
thousand dollars worth of baby essential
items and we're hoping to beat that this
year so to tell the public just just
take it back a little bit about the type
of work that you do we are a non-profit
organization that helps people
experiencing homelessness through
construction Community engagement and
education so on top of our community
engagement projects like this one we
also help build and renovate shelters
wow so for those who are interested in
giving I know that there's going to be
several local locations around Clark
County where they can drop off and
there's even this is what it will look
like like the drop-off location box so
explain it to our audience yeah we have
17 of these boxes around the valley and
for a list of public drop-off locations
you can visit our Facebook page at
facebook.com homeaid snv and there you
can also find a link to our Amazon
wishlist to purchase donations to be
delivered directly to us and lastly for
those attending the the aviators game on
Thursday I'm hearing that you get some
sort of discount or something like that
yes if you bring by an item you'll get a
coupon for five dollars off a concession
item five dollars off thank you so much
Taylor we appreciate you joining along
you know joining us this morning and for
a full list of drop-off locations we'll
have that on our website enewsnow.com
send it right back to you in the studio
reporting live Joshua peguero eight news
now excellent so easy to grab those when
you're at the store and help out Joshua
thank you